[Music]
featuring one dog on the table and three
on the floor yeah but this one really
wants it doesn't matter he's not good
enough this one it's no it's 2020 okay
we're laying down the law this year no
Kerman on the table no no that's what we
decided remember we talked about all we
did yeah no I don't I don't recall why
I'm just feeling your material it's a
Seinfeld episode are you just touching
my shirt because it's me Andes is three
times softer than cotton and this is the
new robe that you can get from unities
speaking of manatees guys when you go to
meet undies calm sausage angeling at 15%
off your first pair of free shipping I
hate a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee with the softest underwear
robes brah let's onesies socks that you
can get check them out right now and use
the link down below or the one I just
read to get a nice little discount and
guys use Post minutes okay get all your
favorite restaurants delivered right to
your front door and right now 24 hours a
day okay and if you work nights if you
work days whatever it is there's gonna
be something impose minutes for you so
go to post mates calm or download the
app use code general you get $100 a free
delivery credit for your first seven
days check it out we use it all the time
and is a great app it literally gets
your favorite food delivered to your
house or your work wherever you are so
you're gonna post me that a lot during
our break oh we did oh we did
speaking of break welcome back know you
welcome no you look no you welcome back
you as you can see I changed a whole lot
since you last saw me transformed I
transformed I would say yeah over these
two weeks what was that transformation
like so I put on a pair of pajamas and
then I sat in them for about two weeks
okay
well not okay so I changed my clothes a
little bit who cares if you do but I'm
saying I shut my brain off in your
brains now on okay I turn my brain did
you have any software updates or no
there was nothing
there's no over there nothing available
to update what did it would you boot
back up right away or was it a long like
startup process
it was a long startup problem to be
honest I'm exactly the same
okay new year same exact me well you did
watch a good amount of ancient aliens
yes I did can I tell you something I did
over the break oh yeah I want to hear
I'm so embarrassed I'm just an
embarrassing person do you know I was
yes I am yes I don't think you are so
you're not there firstly if your person
is like that you're not embarrassing
then you're not embarrassing who else do
you care about that's so not you as a
matter of fact like every time that we
like drink or have friends over the next
morning I wake up and I'm like Julian am
i embarrassing because I just have like
beer fear where I wake up the next day
and I'm just a name for a beer is that
what it's called what whatever you want
to call it properly yeah I'm always like
Julian am i embarrassing and he's like
no babe you're fine
no babe you're fine yes I just cuz you
say no babe you're fine doesn't mean
that I'm not embarrassing we're getting
off track here but also to does are two
very different examples anyways
I was watching ancient aliens and about
3:00 in the morning I went and bought
myself some moldavite herm it's 20/20
Herman is 20/20 quit your crying guys we
have an Italian Greyhound we're giving
away all it does is cry
leave in the comments if you want it
feed him I walk him I do everything a
dog could ever want and he just cries I
got a little piece of moldavite as you
can see here because let me what does
that thing next to it that looks
dangerous
no it's not I didn't have a chain I
thought I had like a chain sitting
around cuz I just lost the
run your own this old necklace was like
a thing on it
tell us what moldavite is I'm gonna can
I can I guess what it is can I guess
well I trip tonight from Moldova what
that's my guess okay moldavite I'll read
you from Wikipedia okay moldavite is a
forest green olive green or bluish green
vitreous silica projectile rock formed
by a meteorite impact probably in
southern Germany that occurred 15
million years ago it is a type of
tektite but basically it's only found in
like one part of the world I think or
maybe two and it happened from what
people believe is to be a meteor impact
that melted this part of the rock of
that part of the world and it turned
this like awesome cool see-through green
color it's like Libyan desert sand glass
uh-huh it's the same concept some type
of meteor or something hot enough to
ignite and melt the sand into these
glass like objects are just like all
over where you can find them on the
ground and it's super cool seer watches
and aliens King Tutankhamen was buried
with a big pendant that was made of that
desert sand glass no no not all right so
when did they mention moldavite at all
did he or did you look it up after
knowing one of the episodes and they
were like I don't even I don't even
really want to say what the episode is
about because I feel like it's funny and
embarrassing but like they were like is
it possible that though the Holy Grail
was made entirely of moldavite and I'm
like I don't know what that means but I
like the idea of a tech guy only being
formed in one part of the world and that
you can buy little pieces of it for
jewelry or for whatever you want and
then it's cool and then and then oh I'm
listening
I started looking at little pieces of it
that were also sold with Herkimer
diamonds which is actually a type of
really hard quartz that is found in
upstate New York which I knew was the
thing but I thought Herkimer diamonds
were found Lots place because I grew up
in never say upstate New York so you see
them like in jewelry they're super
pretty that it's just like it looks like
a little diamond without all the fiery
quality okay now it's clear
like maybe a cubic zirconia with less of
that fiery quality cool damn girl those
look really good for fake diamonds you
know I'm saying
but apparently Herkimer diamonds because
they're so clear and powerful and
stabilizing energy that people use
moldavite as like for crystal healing as
a way of transformation apparently
they're very powerful as you can see
I've already transformers you're looking
perfect same person that I was you're a
new person yeah you know completely
transformed I honestly when I came into
the podcast I was like wait a minute so
then I started looking at moldavite
jewelry pieces with Herkimer diamonds as
a way to stabilize the transformative
energy of moldavite and then I was like
I should look up some other gemstones
and see what they mean and you girl fell
down a crystal hole and now I understand
how they're like plants like once you
learn about one and a little bit about
something else then you're like what's
this one do Wow what's that one of us is
this gonna be a new hobby no it's so I
stopped myself or her because I was like
you know what I don't the Lucifer out
that gave you some good restraint I'm
proud of you you know I think don't ha
ha is to spend a bunch of money on
beautiful things gemstones but I don't I
don't let's just buy this one little
piece of moldavite and see how it makes
me feel yeah that's not gonna be the
only one you buy no 100% they're getting
more I I said I'm not that interested do
you know I'm saying yeah but I fell down
the hole of like looking into it cuz I'm
curious but I'm not interested okay I'm
saying yeah okay no you're being rude
I'm not being rude I'm not the I'm
listening rude I'm just saying we'll see
you say you'll get one
say you maybe get a couple more that's
it no but I was I feel like I was into
it like when I was a kid like you know
your birthstone and that kind of stuff
and then little gemstones like a little
opal here a little moonstone you're like
oh that's so pretty I like I like
gemstones because I like the way that
they look I'm not super invested I get
that I get that all of the rest of the
qualities I get that but I like to think
that some of them are a little too
expensive for me to be like this is a
hobby no [ __ ] you buy in jewelry you
know what I'm saying no I think they're
like I'm it's time right now it's gross
oh my god no I definitely think it's a
it's interesting for a lot of different
reasons
well that that sort of thing could be
interesting to a person so I'm not I'm
not slamming at all I think it's cool
all I'm saying is I could have gone down
a really really crazy rabbit hole cuz
there's lots of cool stuff out there you
could have turned into Hank I just I got
a little piece of moldavite because I
it's a form from a meteor 14 15 million
years ago and I think that's so cool it
is cool touch it it just has like these
really cool patterns and it's like the
pictures of the ones that are like big
and crazy or just I think they're
beautiful so well Congrats on your on
your new acquiring of moldavite that's
very exciting I just feel like you're
judging me no I'm I'm congratulating you
though this is about this is about but
congratulating and reinforcing our
two-week relaxation and whatever we
accomplished or didn't accomplish from
it so I'm saying congrats on acquiring
your new moldavite I didn't acquire
anything look at that isn't that cool is
that the same stuff it's moldable yes no
they didn't cut it that's how it forms
sometimes it forms like they call like a
hedgehog pattern well that's pretty cool
isn't it it is cool that's what I think
I didn't acquire anything during my
break yeah they can't see it so I'm
showing you they can look up pictures of
moldavite and also it just looks like
poop kinda you know but like I'm doing
what do you mean it's just like it's a
green
stone it looks nothing like poop um it
was my mom's birthday it was cute it was
your mom's birthday we did this here for
a birthday birthday little web happy
belated birthday to the webbing machine
if you guys feel like tweeting her a
happy birthday she's wonderful mommy's
the moldavite just let me know I got a
shop on it let me know I think I think
she took you know it's funny we were
talking today and she brought it up
she's like yeah no I'm all good with x
the way I don't have I don't need
anymore moldavite yeah we didn't we
didn't spend we actually spent Christmas
as our family like us and it was really
nice usually each year or either driving
up to see your family up north or you
know I'm seeing my family down here or
something's happening with family and
this year it really felt like we were
able to kind of like be our own family
and we had bunny and we spent Christmas
and New Year's at home and it was really
nice it was like a it was it was very
own theme with our turn off for the
holidays and relax
we got the house all festive and we made
some really fun food it was really fun
it was nice you know
yeah and as the break now closes I know
we don't want it to know but do you have
any thoughts about I don't know 2020 I
come excited or I don't know I'm excited
to go back to work in to to like get
back out of the house a little bit and
just spread my wings a little bit I had
my hybrid laughing I'm smiling I'm
trying to be charming I have my
hibernation I could hibernate until it's
springtime okay so you're gonna okay
that's fine I can run out and get some I
can get us our food and and go out into
the world ya know I could hibernate till
spring that's fine that's fine you don't
me and II should market one of their
like onesies as a hibernation onesie
yeah I'd be down me and he's taking this
idea okay this one's on the house it's a
onesie
it's super thick right and it's you can
market it as it's thicker than a bear's
fur but don't actually make it thicker
than a browser because who the hell is
gonna even know
and then there's pockets everywhere for
food one some of them are refrigerated
pockets some of them are pantry pockets
and there's a hood that goes completely
over
not only your head but it wraps your
whole body it like turns you into a big
ball of onesie yeah and there's
ventilation holes it's very scientific
again you're welcome you can have that
idea for free just if you make if you
make them send me one and one for Jenna
too and one for good measure it's so
gross having like sleeping with all your
food all and it has Auto washing fabric
so the micro modal is not only three
times softer than cotton but it's three
times cleaner than cotton at all times
because it has a built-in microbes I
think you're thinking of microbial
Jillian microbials that's not the same
thing it is just because it has the word
micro in microbial fabric no Mike
a guy named Mike invents it actually
this is not shark tank I'm getting
carried away like I would be in my
hibernation paired in my me undies
hibernation onesie anyway it's yep
I hope you guys had a good break too I
mean we we really didn't do much which
was nice and it's what we planned on you
know we like children the house we
actually saw some friends which is cool
we got to hang out with Lexie and we
went out to West Hollywood for a little
bit yeah yeah and drink on New Year's I
just feel like as much as I could do
nothing forever this is my favorite
thing to do I have a little bit of the
like the going back to the world blues
you know but for sure it's definitely
better for me than to do nothing for
forever you know I would agree yeah I
mean I would totally agree and I think
that there I think that's a feeling that
a lot of people can probably identify
with yeah which is like you have a
really fun break or weekend or whatever
is and come Sunday you're like damn I'm
sad I have to go back to whatever school
work but once you get back into it and
you start you know moving back in your
routine and you know things are moving
it feels good you know and it feels like
you're you're doing stuff I'm also just
like when I'm on my little break here
yeah I'm just like the worst version of
myself the laziest like calories don't
count like I don't got to do anything I
don't want to do I'm just like a I'm a
blogger a little sloth I'm a little slow
I don't think that's the worst version
of you though I feel like whenever I do
that whenever I'm on like my little
nothing break I'm like I'm just
indulging in all of the worst parts of
me which aren't like I'm gonna sleep in
stay up late eat bad food like I just
think it's so fun but I'm like [ __ ] if
you did this forever you suck I think
you I think we're similar in that way
because something about our past and
something about you know our early 20s
and when we worked a lot of jobs and we
weren't really comfortable and we had to
do a lot of [ __ ] it's sort of like
ingrained in our minds that like the
moment we're able to not do this we're
gonna really [ __ ] take advantage of
that and I think I have that too you
know and so when I feel really bad yeah
and then you get like way over indulging
like okay let's let's calibrate here but
balance balance it's all about right but
leading up to the break your life is not
balanced and that you need a break so
then you take the break it and you're
overworked yeah now you go back yeah
exactly
life is all about balance except we're
not balanced at all so take that advice
too much to people who are completely
unbalanced we overwork ourselves to the
point of exhaustion and then we do
nothing for two weeks yeah I would say
my life is unbalanced because I spend
the majority of my time and day just
doing nothing but cooing at small
animals so in big animals take whatever
I say with a grain of salt the grain of
Himalayan sea salt
no no grain and mold the bite take it
with a grain of moldavite Jenna 2020
it's gonna transform me
yeah that's the cool thing about
crystals is that you don't have to do
any work it works for you oh you know
I'm starting to get you like these
things now that was a job that's good
you know it's not a joke what getting
your favorite restaurants delivered to
your house 24 hours a day seven days a
week
and you know what thank you for that if
if you guys okay if you are still in
shutoff mode and you need your you're
guilty food your guilty pleasure food
whatever post mates is there for you but
but if you guys are now you know new
years new me you know working on your
diet and trying to make sure you're
eating the right things and you have
very specific things that you want to
eat and maybe you don't really feel like
cooking at all there's a cool function
on post meats that I actually have been
using where you can search mount
restaurants but food you can search the
menus the whole entire menu database on
posting it so you search and then you
click menu or food not restaurants and
you can search Batman themed vegetables
strawberries whatever it is tofu
whatever your thing is okay fruit shake
chocolate I don't know what your your
what your trying to eat but it makes it
so you can order things like ala carte
which makes you know if you're cooking
if your meal prepping or if you're
cooking something you don't want to like
deal with the vegetables part of it you
just look up some steamed vegetables
nearly oh I'll just get that deliver it
and post mates can serve a lot of
different purposes for you so I've been
doing that I think it's super helpful
and I just wanted to let you guys know
that post mates is great and even when
you're not being naughty with your food
you can use poast minutes to your
advantage
naughty naughty and they also have
salads I don't know salads are cool too
if you like that kind of thing guys if
you go to the App Store download the
post mates app use code generally you
get $100 of free delivery credit for
your first seven days of using the app
and then you have an app that delivers
food to your house after that period
ends so it's like a win-win-win and when
you're hungry you get fed so check it
out
also guys get yourself some me Andes
right now it's it's a cooler time of
year and you might want a nice cozy
onesie or a pair of underwear or
bralette or this beautiful robe
three times softer than cotton their
underwear is unparalleled literally the
best underwear I've ever put on my
bottom my underwear drawer is blessed to
be full with me undies and they have all
new designs all the time they have very
plain basic colors if that's your thing
or they have really loud designs that
are very exciting if that's your thing
they also make for great gifts I know
Valentine's Day is just now around the
corner so just saying you know could be
a good little Valentine's Day gift for
that special someone you can get
matching underwear it's pretty great
they have actually a program for that
where you can get matching pairs in two
different styles for you and yours
anyway go to meet undies comm slash
Jenna Julian for 15% off your first pair
and free shipping you will not regret it
great underwear great product yet can I
tell them what we did on Christmas Day
yeah what do we do
we ate latkes and Chinese food that
Julie made oh yeah we watched an entire
season of Survivor oh my god we watched
survivor
we had a Jewish Christmas and we watched
all of Survivor
it was so fun what island of the idols
was the name of the season we watched
very good season and I had a lot of fun
I miss survivor it had been a long time
since we watched and we binge two whole
season in one day night it was perfect
it was perfect yeah that was a good
Christmas can we go back yeah I had such
a good time it was really fun it was
really fun
we made the latkes recipe that I made on
my channel what cheese in it and then we
made orange chicken right orange chicken
Chinese food and I said oh how you make
that but it is so good cuz you make it
with tofu yeah but that's not the hard
part it's getting the sauce right that's
the hard part how do you make the sauce
fresh-squeezed orange juice yeah but
what else a lot of different ingredients
like you need you need like vinegar you
need oranges
I forget I don't know you need vinegar
and oranges and tofu yeah but like oh my
god don't put those three together all
right it's so acidic oh you need a lot
of sugar
oh yeah no that sounds much you need a
lot of sugar I don't know there's a
recipe somewhere but it's it was really
good it was good food don't don't touch
him why can't I touch him because he's
my guy and you already offered us a long
is so dry for those of you that don't
know also by the way when Kermit had his
teeth out he has three teeth left mm-hmm
I don't think I ever said that I don't
think you did either he only has three
teeth left so that's why his tongue now
hangs all the way out all the way up but
what's cute is that it hangs out the
same side as marble they both hang out
their tongues to the left yeah but yeah
you got three left bud but don't worry
he's still just as nasty as he was
before mmm I really does hang all the
way out though yeah like marble I feel
like does a good job somehow putting it
back in and like keeping it totally sure
I said God let this thing dry out he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and then when he
drools it drips all the way down his
tongue which is already like all the way
out like oh he's just so gross no no
that's disgusting it's either like
really dry or soaking wet you know sorry
bunny had her first Christmas which was
really nice she was very festive and
enjoyed it and for a lot of walks she
liked the tree she'd got used to the
tree in about 30 seconds well we have
those lights that you can control like
they're what LED lights or whatever yeah
they're like Bluetooth comes in a string
of Bluetooth control plates so right
when we put it up Julian made it do like
some fancy flashing Christmas cheer like
she did not like that there's an office
so we found a setting that was just like
stagnant lights and she was fine with
that mm-hmm
but I thought she was gonna be more
scared of the tree but she wasn't yeah
and a lot of you guys were tweeting at
us um know about the fireworks on New
Year's Eve but actually first of all she
did fine she doesn't mind fireworks but
we about a month and a half and having
her it was the fourth of July and that
was the first time when we were actually
really nervous because we knew that they
were gonna be fireworks and she did fine
she really doesn't she doesn't mind the
fireworks it's you know what's weird I
think like trash trucks are the bane of
her existence like she's terrified of
trash trucks still and I think it's it's
a thing where it's it's the sight of it
coupled with the sound of it and the
base of it I think if she were to see
fireworks like if we were outside and we
took her to a firework it would be bread
box I think that that would be the
scariest they'd be cool bird box for her
but when she's like it she really still
like sitting in the game room and she
likes this that like over in her little
corner yeah with that door closed and
the fact that we live in the valley so
there's not a lot of fireworks here
because of fires yeah so you might hear
them in the distance no they're
relatively quiet sir we just haven't
really had a firework issue with her no
but I agree if she ever started in this
car do fireworks
forget it I think she would lose it yeah
I mean it's so weird how the like things
that really spook her or get her
attention are just so visual yeah for
the most part like the trash truck the
trash truck can ruin her entire day can
ruin her day it sucks because sometimes
it'll be coming you know around the
block the first thing in the morning
I'll let her out to go to the bathroom
and she'll just run out and then be like
nope and go all the way back inside be
like [ __ ] this I'm like skip breakfast -
no yeah he's Garret she yeah she still
has I mean it's gonna be a long time
till in me maybe never till she feels
like she can't be scared of or isn't
scared of normal things but the trash
truck thing she's getting better we walk
we're on a walk the other day and there
was a trash truck just kind of sitting
there picking up a big old dumpster and
she was pulling a little bit and like
didn't want to go near and so we stood
there and I just kind of like pet her
and kept her at ease while we watched it
and we watched it drive all the way down
the street and she
kind of looked at it and she's brave
like she's getting more and more
confident and brave with things that she
is was previously like scared to death
of but yeah we don't have problems with
the fireworks no problems with the
fireworks she even saw him on and heard
them on TV like when we we had our
friends over for New Year's just like a
few people and we were in the like a
main room of the house
we're playing beer pong she didn't try
and chase any of the paintballs yeah
mind you we're adults so we play beer
pong like you fill the cups up with
water and everyone just at their only
drinks roantree
zips their own drink it's just for the
fun of playing it without all of the
disgustingness of drooling those cups oh
so like your birthday last year or late
or she wasn't we didn't have her yet no
not for my birthday last year no that
was the last time we had like I guess
people here but like anyone in the house
usually she'll like hang out for a
little bit she's really curious and then
she'll go in the game room and have some
quiet yeah but she sat on the couch and
we had like the New Year's Eve stuff on
TV and we're listening to music and she
sat on the couch and just watched
everything and didn't try to steal the
beer pong balls with so much stimuli
like yeah people talk people talking
there's the noise bouncing well there's
the noise of the New Year's Eve
celebration which is obviously obnoxious
I don't even know why we watched music
it's music and then there's the
fireworks on TV and then there's yet a
ball like the ball bouncing around and
us throwing the ball around like that
not bothering her she was sleeping on
the couch mm-hmm she was watching it in
the sleeping so you just wanted to be
part of the fun yeah we had three people
over plus us we had a total of five
people and yeah I mean if she's like
that kind of thing is six months ago
would have never happened
so no now she's what on season six the
Seinfeld he's on season six of Seinfeld
yeah she just she just got past the
midway point of season six
yeah I'm really proud to her for that
yeah but she didn't have to hear any
actual firework she just saw them on TV
and even that she was okay with yeah
yeah I wouldn't say she you know some
dogs like actually watch TV I wouldn't
say she's like actually watching it I
think she's trying to figure out if some
scenes or some things on the TV are cool
and then when she decides that then
they're fine
then she'll lay down I think I think
she's really there to just be closer to
everybody and have a really comfortable
place I think for the most part you're
right but I do see her sometimes
actually pay attention ya know for sure
it's only inside there's literally some
people that turn their TV on for their
dogs cuz their dog wants to watch it
doesn't yeah yeah our trainer has a dog
argentinos and he turns on the TV for
him and he just sits there
he'll record him and he was like it
looks like a person
yeah it looks like a person like a human
being nobody
um you know I think the humor of
Seinfeld really resonates with her I
think she the pacing and the tone and
the humor and the style of it she
appreciates so everyone some office
we'll just kind of look up I really oh
yeah that's pretty funny
ha wasn't it funny Julianne come lay
back and I'm like [ __ ] no and she also
knows I mean we haven't been up in this
room in two weeks and just now Jenna was
like you wanna go podcast podcast and
she sprinted up here yeah because she
likes sitting on that bed in that corner
in that spot so I think she missed the
podcasts she looks so funny when she
comes up in that bed she just looks so
small she just US cooing in our dog off
mic and our sake podcast I did I know I
know it's 20/20 but I just when I saw
that when I saw the you know cuz it
happens on the East Coast first and the
Singapore and yeah you see it before
it's like happening and it says like
happy 2020 and it just like hit me for a
second I was like what a weird
futuristic number that's a weird
futuristic number it doesn't feel quite
real when you think about the numbers of
it also I saw something that said we're
closer to 2050 than 1990 oh no I just
[ __ ] out oh no it's very scary 2050 oh
no oh no but from now on it's like every
number of past 2021 that's a futuristic
number 2022 that's a futuristic number
2023 that's a future hold on I'm not
done 2024 that's a futuristic number
2025 you know what that is futuristic
number 20 hold on 2026 2025 is the year
that hopefully we'll get some nice
competitive self-driving vehicles on the
market for the non luxury car market
have you talked about your plan for cars
I don't know I feel like I have maybe
you have maybe we're just maybe we're
just getting old and repeating ourselves
like your parents do I've already if I
haven't just in case or you haven't
heard it I like to shout it from a
rooftop that I'm not buying another
vehicle that I have to drive the next
vehicle that I buy will be a car that
drives me but I'm not interested in a
Tesla or any type of luxury car I want
like a self-driving fully automated
binning minivan that I can gut out and
pin all my dogs in cut it out cut it out
fill the back with carpet sit back there
with my dogs
and they have it drive me around I mean
that sounds nice you think 2025 is the
year that's gonna happen
2025 I feel like is when you might see
like a Honda self truck with
self-driving technology that mind you
obviously that's still the kind we need
to sit in the driver's seat yeah you're
talking about full on uber self-driving
like you get in the backseat and that
[ __ ] drives around well so I still
think that even with the it's like a
Tesla
you can't sit in the backseat of your
Tesla with no one in the driver's seat
and have it drive you that won't work
yeah I I think that that's possible but
like not right now we still need yeah I
still need to operate yeah but 2025 I
think is one you'll see a competitive
marketplace for vehicles that aren't
Tesla's yeah yeah for sure because I
dunno like Jaguar and like you know
mercedes-benz and that kind of stuff
they're making self you know the luxury
cars are doing it first yeah so that you
could buy a instead of just having your
option via Tesla you could buy a
Mercedes that has self-driving
technology yeah well I don't think it's
I don't think it's really surprising
anyone that the future is definitely to
be self-driving at this point right like
or electric or electric but mostly
self-driving I think like I think what I
think is gonna happen is like as more
cars start to develop self-driving tech
and as more of that as implemented to
cars that are actually on the road we're
gonna see a huge decrease in accidents I
think that's what's gonna happen and
that's going to be sort of the turning
point to where people are like ok this
is the direction we should go no no
that's what I think though I don't care
about that I only care because I don't
want to drive myself well I don't care
about anything I mean I obviously would
love fewer accidents don't get me wrong
but like my reasoning is why would I pay
my money to drive myself around cuz
driving oh I'll pay my money so it
drives me I mean I get that it's not
like a dad joke like oh how much money
you pay for that car I better Drive you
yeah I've definitely heard my dad tell
me that joke yeah my car is gonna drive
me it is who's laughing now dad yeah and
it's a minivan Oh God my car my car by
the way it bought in 2012 and it's been
sitting dead in the garage I don't drive
it the deadest Carver I don't drive it
because I'm angry at it I'm resentful at
it Wow
what did it do wrong what how did it
wrong you it it didn't I made it up in
my head okay I loved it
okay it was like you know a big circus
for me I was really excited I felt like
a real adult you know yeah and um I just
don't drive it so I keep letting it die
well you have a pretty cool boyfriend
who drives around it's cool Jeep so I
asked him to drive me everywhere
mostly because I have nowhere to go
jim-jim in the grocery store you know
which we do go to every single day
pretty much so I mean it's not that I
never leave my house but um I'm just not
driving yeah
so I I'm like if I could buy a car then
has a Julianne built-in you know got it
okay well however self driving this car
maybe it's not gonna have the charm of
the good looks of a Julianne so just
warning you for that oh yeah I just like
why why would I take my money in the
years 20 to 20 25 I don't think you're I
want like a sick sick what is what is
the UM like Honda minivan call the pilot
yeah like up I want like a dope pilot
that drives me is it a pilot I don't
know I just made that up so I don't
think you're wrong I think if you guys
have a cool boyfriend who drives you
around for the time being or a few
Coover or if you take public transfer
you wait a little bit and I think see
what Jenna does at 125 and then maybe
use that as your I don't know I have a
very unique circumstance that allows me
to wait five years to just be like well
I mean some no I do think that is true
but also I think you don't in that
people always they're kind of like
planning out when they're gonna get
their next car or when they're gonna say
but you know and so I think thinking
about it in that respect is something
that people could relate to is well yeah
I mean when I bought my car I bought it
to have it for at least ten years so
it's probably what eight years that's
been eight years so
in you know another two years I would be
ready to start considering buying
another car so I'm like what am i
selling that one if I could stretch that
out another couple years guess what year
it is
25 20 25 the time when I theoretically
proposed that we may have the
competitive market 20 25 we're going
based on no research whatsoever
you've looked it up maybe a little bit
but not a lot and it's also no guarantee
nothing you say is based on no research
you research things without you like
don't expose me like this 20 25 we're
gonna be sitting here levitating on the
podcast that's gonna be so futuristic
we're gonna get rid of these chairs and
we're just gonna be floating like that
you see what I did that's how we're
gonna be floating podcast from your car
we think about that car cast car cast
but we don't have to drive will do all
still hassle your hair we're gonna know
someone has no one has to drive we'll
we'll rig up cameras will do all the
podcasts with you we'll go on a
worldwide tour in your car podcasting on
the road outside of every major city in
the driver seat not in twenty five
twenty five you can't just no it's an
app on your phone in 2025 actually it's
implanted in your brain back mayor okay
if you found your perfect Honda
beautiful mini that drove itself great
safety rating literally no strings
attached except for one string one
string what's this Jay had to implement
the car keys in your brain absolutely
not and it's free absolutely not no way
how about that absolutely no not in your
brain in your result nope not in your
not into it so the car keys can't live
inside you know but it's tiny it's a
microchip no even if we had the
microchip technology for people now like
you know we we just spent all that time
going to the DMV getting our real IDs or
whatever you need them to fly if they
gave you the option to put a chip in you
the way that they've always theorized
they're like you know let me I
oh I will I will wait until the
government tells me I have to do it yeah
I do not want it in my body you think
that doesn't that's my personal
preference know my body I echo that
statement I will also not be putting
government property inside my body
weight but also but also you really were
one of the last people I knew to give in
to the face ID thing you really didn't
want to do that
well I'm I'm happy to report that it
doesn't ever [ __ ] recognize me so ok
absolutely breath I just love how you're
like no I if I if I do face ID the the
government's gonna know what I look
[ __ ] snapchat has known exactly that
yes in some respect you did say that you
didn't want you didn't want your facial
recognition being in a database yeah I
wasn't Julian but snapchats been doing
that for years
what do you say I'm like on the internet
constantly like if the government wants
to know who I look like personally
there's enough information that exists
on the internet from snapchat from
everything no it wasn't that I just
don't want my phone looking at my face
and recognizing my face console I just
don't want its facial mapping it's art I
never said that I don't want my face in
a database of government information as
if if somebody wanted my my facial
technologies already there you might say
no no I didn't Julian that wasn't my
reasoning that's okay oh no you making
me mad no why are you adjusting to put
on face ID on your phone because you
didn't want I said I don't want your
face yes that's it that's what I said
hello no you were like as if snapchat
hasn't already existed it's true yeah
which is why I had no problem using
snapchat because it's [ __ ] fun but we
all knew that that technology was
getting used okay they were using that
right oh yeah I think so
but isn't that the whole thing like
having a Google home and an Alexa didn't
their to use one and like a criminal
trial
yes they did they're all over the house
we now have one that has a camera on it
that's not fun
wait what is the name of that one the
Alexa what is it called
I don't know Big Daddy we have the
Amazon Big Daddy
which is the Alexa with a screen and a
camera on it we should cover that camera
okay Julie so they can't get an extra
angle when I'm doing my cooking videos
okay fair enough all right fair enough
you understood the facial recognition
software was already out there
absolutely right finds everyone
oh just why everyone's like the whole
FBI man meme it's like true but not true
but like it's just a joke because it's
like we've all sort of booter up I want
to see if it recognizes you just did it
work well it's locked
no it's unlocked that's what the unlock
logo is for then you just swipe up we
have you been doing it wrong
oh my god so you have to swipe the slave
when the lock turns to an unlock and it
stays on the house that means it
recognized yes oh no but it gives me the
light touch pattern a lot okay here let
me take my glasses on it was already
unlocked hold on it's working perfectly
no it's not I'm telling you it gives me
the the number pad all the time you know
you can program multiple faces into one
phone so I could unlock your phone with
my face well you do not come near my
phone you know what is that when you
like help me set this up I probably look
just like this cuz I look like this all
the time if I have makeup on him
probably is when it doesn't it like
regularly doesn't recognize me yeah I
think that was a big that was a big like
thing on YouTube like as soon as facial
recognition they did the makeup look
versus their regular look right yeah I
just looked the same those years
recognize every time yeah but you always
look the same what the heck is that even
supposed to mean rude
no here's that here's here's how my face
differs from time to time my hair will
be completely messy my glasses will be
on and/or off my facial hair will change
a little bit like these are all things
that don't really affect a facial
recognition algorithm I don't think if
you even want to call it an algorithm
let me know what's called I do some
heavy base shape and contour yeah I
don't I just let it all hang out
Babette robber what do you got planned
for this year didn't do some big things
huh
I just want my self-driving minivan
without the keys implanted into my brain
which is all right so questions all
right so no keys implanted in your brain
that's fine what if the government
knocked on our front door and was like
yeah I put this in your brain no I don't
want to that's when we're living in
black Maritimes you know oh my god 2020
it's boring black mirror times now well
I gotta go I gotta go I'm scared okay
well I hope you guys had a good New Year
I hope you guys are feeling refreshed
and back to your routines and I hope
whatever resolutions or goals you have
for this year happen for you and I max
I'm excited for this year I think
there's a lot on the horizon to be
excited about and what yeah yeah and
2020 I don't know it's just a weird
[ __ ] number I can't I can't even
understand that that's that you were
living in it's a it's like a very
science fiction novel it's a sci-fi
number yeah I don't know well in 2020 if
you guys have any ideas for the podcast
only for this year we'll take your ideas
we've never done it before and we'll
never do it again but let us know if you
have ideas for the podcast this year
only and we'll try to make them happen i
screenshot something like over the break
cuz there was a little bit on the
internet but like not really but I saw
one the other day that I was like oh we
doing that one oh yeah but I forget what
it was
thank God for screenshots oh this one
someone dull Becky on Twitter said I
will literally buy this and send it to
you guys who played on the podcast I
need to hear Julian bullshitting all of
these it's a game called what's the plot
a party game for people who like to talk
[ __ ] how it works
sounds good you take a prompt card tell
us you're there here's our examples tell
us your superhero origin story tell us
about why you are not welcome in Canada
anymore oh yeah yeah yeah tell us about
the time you had to say goodbye to your
imaginary friend oh yeah this is tell us
about the time your mom told you she
couldn't cope with your furry addiction
any longer yeah else would be incredible
at that Jeff Jeff we should have him
back to do that one that is funny
you know also begin to that Chris metal
burger he is he's gonna that they just
they're good on the spot they make Jeff
would make some really like intricate
crafted story was very strongly
developed characters and Chris would
just tell us like a very funny joke
yeah I love a friend I love our friends
too we got good friends
we got good friends we also have a
podcast that we were supposed to do on
the last one but we ran out of time and
it's an idea that we came up with digits
yes that we got that one in the bank -
you know we're cooking baby we got all
these ideas you please sit there so it's
like tight don't you know that was the
idea that was me unlocking I'm the phone
I recognized you it's like instant it
recognized your face so far I don't know
I'd see it so good right now I'm telling
you like I'll just be sitting at my desk
and I'll look at it and it just like
number pad every time I'm sorry but it's
just doing it it's just like me laugh so
hard thinking about you picking up your
phone and waiting for it to like
actually swipe itself up when you need
to right I didn't realize that that
little unlock symbol meant
yeah that means usually that's yeah but
I don't just sit there and go like this
and not swipe up I know but I'm
imagining you on your own be like Julian
my phone where you're steering I just
open it how do I open it how do I turn
it on okay well you're toxic I'm toxic I
am you're you're right about that have a
great rest of your week we'll see you
guys next week on the podcast we're
gonna be live on Twitch this week doing
stuff I think we're gonna start Detroit
this week Detroit become human we're
gonna start that on PC this week we're
gonna probably do like a stream a week
of Detroit where we play a handful of
hours together so get excited about that
and your laughs and we'll tweet on the
Jenna Jillian account when we're live
with Detroit because I know a lot of you
asking about it but happy 2020 we love
all you very much and thanks for being
here we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]